The Sun is White... and 8 other Astronomy
Facts
1.
The energy required to stop the Earth orbiting
the sun is about 2.6478 × 10^33 joules or
7.3551 × 10^29 watt hours or 6.3285*10^17
megatons of TNT.
For reference, the largest nuclear explosion
ever detonated (the Tsar Bomba by the Soviet
Union) produced 50 megatons of TNT worth of
energy.
So assuming the Earth wouldn’t be obliterated
in the process, it would take about 12,657,000,000,000,000
of those nuclear bombs detonated at the correct
location to stop the Earth in its tracks.
2.
In 2011, astronomers discovered an enormous
12 billion year old water reservoir floating
in space estimated to be about the volume
of 140 trillion Earth oceans!
This further confirmed the theory that water
has been present in the universe for much
of its existence, with our universe about
13.8 billion years old.
(QF 723)
3.
Russian cosmonaut Sergei Krikalev has spent
more time in space than any other human in
history.
How long?
803 days, 9 hours and 39 minutes.
That is approximately 2.2 years, over the
span of six spaceflights.
(QF 775)
4.
You are simultaneously hurtling around the
sun at 66,600 mph while sitting on a rock
that is spinning at 1,070 mph.
On top of that, our whole solar system is
rocketing through space around the center
of the Milky Way at around 559,234 mph.
On top of that, our galaxy is hurtling through
space at around 671,080 mph, with respect
to our local group of galaxies.
On top of that, for all we know, our entire
Universe is hurtling through some unknown
medium at some other ridiculous speed.
5.
It takes approximately 225 million Earth years
for our solar system to make one trip around
the Milky Way.
Our solar system has made this trip approximately
20.4 times since it formed about 4.6 billion
Earth years ago.
6.
In 5 to 6 billion years, the Sun will be around
the peak of its Red Giant phase, and according
to many of the latest models, even with the
Sun losing quite a bit of mass during this
process, thus making the Earth’s orbit farther
out, the Sun should just barely consume the
Earth.
This won’t matter match to us though as
in about 1 to 2 billion years or so, the Sun’s
brightness will have increased sufficiently
to vaporize all water on the surface of the
Earth.
Bottom line, at some point in the next billion
years or so, humans will need to either find
another home, or figure out how to manually
move our current one to a farther out orbit,
keeping Earth in the changing habitable zone
of our solar system.
7.
The dwarf planet Pluto takes 248 Earth years
to orbit the Sun; meaning that since its discovery
in 1930, it has only traveled around 33% of
its orbit.
(QF 511)
8.
While it only takes 8 minutes and 19 seconds
for the light from the surface of the sun
to reach Earth, it actually takes about 10,000-170,000
years for a photon to travel from the core
of the sun to the surface.
9.
If you could look at the Sun outside of our
atmosphere (without blinding yourself), you’d
see that the Sun actually is white in the
human visual spectrum, not yellow, despite
being classified as a yellow dwarf.